[Music]
and remember if you subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel for
free you never miss another episode you
just click the subscribe button
at the bottom of the right right of the
screen now
now britain's vaccine rollout per capita
continues to storm ahead of most other
nations
with around 5 million vaccinations
likely by this weekend
the success has roiled much of britain's
media which is
often at its happiest revealing
weaknesses in the government's
pandemic response and there has been
plenty of them
so this week it had to console itself by
wondering aloud if pfizer supplies
has slowed down and of course it fell
back on its old
favorite chestnut post code lottery
failing to understand that unless you
keep a central grip
on the roll out as they have in scotland
which has hardly been a success story
then some regional variation is
inevitable
and it's not always the result of
incompetence either
but before we get on to the vaccines the
big news today
is about the react study from imperial
college london which shows in its words
the coronavirus infections are not
falling
in england so what's going on well the
spectator
publishes covert data every day on its
new hub
at spectator dot co dot uk
data and here's editor fraser nelson
to take us through it fraser thank you
andrew yes the imperial react study
is certainly big news it's one of the
biggest studies taken in this country
there's something like
140 000 people who volunteer
to be tested and the findings were in
imperial's own words that the rate
of new infections was not dropping in
the early days
of lockdown now this sent shock waves
around quite a few government
departments because ministers had
thought
things were getting better the lockdown
was doing pretty much
what people thought they were going to
do and that they might be lifted
in february and we might move back to
the tier
system but if this big study
contradicted that then it wasn't quite
clear how you can reconcile what it was
saying
with the official data now let's go back
to the start of the current stage
encodes
the kent variant we can see that this
started to rise
during the last lockdown now this was
what really were administers that if it
could rise throughout
broke down two what reason was there to
think that lockdown three
might put a stop to it so if a new
variant had spread certainly into london
perhaps
nationally you can see a scenario where
infections were rising exponentially
and even the most forceful tools at the
government's disposal
wouldn't stop it that was the concern
and quite a well-justified concern when
lockdown
3 was announced at the beginning of
january it takes a while for the coveted
figures to settle but let's have a look
at what's happened in kent
and in london since then we've seen a
sharp decline
in both places almost 50 percent
now the case is they can change what
really matters is hospital caseload
so let's look at covert admissions in
london hospitals
we can see them absolutely surging here
during december almost troubling during
that month
and reaching a peak of almost a thousand
admissions a day
in january the sixth now again let's
have a look at what's happened since
then
these admissions have fallen to about
650
a day that's a drop of about a third
overall
the hospitals are still very stretched
that's true in london
it's true nationally it's especially
true for intensive care
units but we have seen a decline in the
number of admissions in london
which was the epicenter of this new
variant
now let's have a look at england as a
whole you can see there
that the positive tests which again take
quite a few days to settle
seem to have com peaked at about the new
year
and then declining so the same rough
trend
all around the country so this is the
puzzle how do we
reconcile this official daily data and
the hospital data
with the imperial study saying that the
virus is not falling
well that's a little easier to
understand if you look at how the
imperial study takes its data
it does two big samples the last one was
in january the six it started then
but it compares it to the previous
sample which was taken at the end of
november
and the beginning of december so the
imperial study missed
both the um december surge and the
january peak
now the imperial react study is one of
many studies now looking at covid there
are
for example we've got the zoe study run
by king's college
they save a number of new covered
infections has been cut in half
since the new year peak that's one piece
of good news but overall
there's not much good news we can still
see the levels of covert even now
they're lower than they were in the new
year but they're still
far higher several times higher than
they were a few months ago
and we've got the death figures which
always lag infections
they're terrible and every day we're
seeing depths climb towards
almost the peak which we had during the
first wave there is no
reason to look in these figures and see
any reason to lower your guard
but nor is there any reason to think
that things are getting exponentially
worse
in january as had been rationally feared
at the beginning of the year
things do seem to be improving and there
does seem to be rational grounds for
hoping
that when lockdown restrictions are
reviewed in the middle of february
we might be able to move back to the
tier system
[Music]
you